welcome the new studio Brian you have
not you walked in having no idea well
that's because that's because I had for
Harrison County's town all day dude
no and it looks amazing well no late now
no now hold on he came in tree goes you
didn't notice the studio brings I said
about it no no I was very impressed look
at my jeans yeah yeah Brian I had four
pairs of [ __ ] jeans done what are you
James up we had to be done with Adam hem
so they fit my legs love this that a
little cuz I got short legs and then I
am DUP once you spike shorter Jean the
guy did a terrible job and I'm gonna go
back gave you bell-bottoms yeah and
that's that looks cool on you okay look
hehe cool if I was in the 70s I want to
come back I'm gonna go to the [ __ ]
guy oh my god hey dude all good
do you have a time machine do you have a
time machine here he gave you the boot
cuz you know I got a problem but you
just like they were too long yeah what
should I buy either this is for jeans
sir - god I put them on they were all
they were all here watch this denim I'm
a stand up stand up jeans ever like the
same way they flare out to the side
[ __ ] time that's not that bad dude I
haven't seen you once where the gucci
boots we got you I know I bought these
though not really gucci boots look sweet
in those in that outfit I'm very
self-conscious about it know where I'm
yeah but where them they're made to be
worn I'm gonna they get better when you
wear in yeah I'm gonna I like him a lot
how was San Fran buddy the best yet
funny what's what's not to love about
father nice the amazing weather in
amazing weather Hong with my boy yo yo
yo see ya
wifey she's not she was actually up in
Chicago so he was alone he was solo
oh so it's just you two you have nothing
better yes it's one of the best yep you
know he's a cop so I walked in with a
tight shirt to work out and empower have
to do he stood up and pulled his shirt
up and went if you're gonna pull your
gun out up oh my god you're gonna put
your guns oh wow yeah cuz I'm pretty
shredded then he looked at me he goes
I'm front of everybody he goes dude you
see this vein he's actually funny
because she's vein and you see how this
is coming out you're doing some [ __ ] bro
and you didn't tell us and he walked
away
that I'm not because you [ __ ] take an
anavar that's funny
hey everybody thank you so much for
sending me all these information on afar
and thank you so much for offering to
send me out of all I appreciate I'm good
though I'm gone now I haven't decided
what and I will reach out when I decide
you to go I have a little research on
your profiles
it's private can't buy from you you're
some dude excited I'm gonna look into it
then I have people who are so sweet and
wonderful who are like please don't
he causes a heart attacks and thank you
guys for taking care of me if you see
the one who says don't do anavar it
really doesn't do anything yeah I mean
you know it's it's the it's steroid
light you know it's what women use and
body makes fun of you if you take an
imam a turian first so much for taking
anymore i know how big of a roid I think
it's gonna shred you take it I don't
think I because it's not how big of a
roid head you have to be if somebody's
like they're like all laughing high five
testosterone or an animal okay but see
yeah
whoo tar who's you have who opened for
him cops
local oh yeah good scene out there sighs
good scene good guys local comics really
good did you hang out with them or no
not really cuz that was with I have so
many friends there John Fitch came to my
show loved it
yeah right yo realize that big years oh
no John yeah John's got a wide face very
he's just he's just [ __ ] great you
guys he's a great guy really good great
guy dude that was so funny - he was
telling me how he you know he's such a
monster and he was telling because I
yeah I can't marahau the subject came up
but it came up with something somebody
said to me you're good at you're funny
when I came offstage I go oh yeah I'm
really funny oh yeah I've been doing
this 225 years so I'm super funny a
quarter be funny yeah one of the best by
the way how about that never say that
about anything else in my life really so
he goes so Johnson yeah yeah it's funny
I I was asked to come
Rhodos doing a seminar and they asked me
to come roll with the school there and I
was a little nervous cuz I want some 19
year old taking off at all how is that
you know I didn't know then he goes
inside the blue world now and I was and
I kind of was like oh and then once you
started rolling he was like oh I'm
better than ever
he's really good yeah he was like I
forgot I roll with khabib yeah I was
like guys he said such a funny thing
about cubby if he goes yeah you know um
I go how do you do with could be because
um well first of all I go he's smaller
than you and he goes he's about I
guarantee right now he's 195 number-one
INGOs boy and number two he's like I
have to be in shape and then he said
something stuff like John Fitch he goes
maybe I can stand up once like I get I
get on my feet why lose the stories I've
heard from that camping Kabir I was just
like legend oh my god John Fitch's say
laughs yeah they laugh yeah and if you
ask ten even if kebede ever gonna lose
like never know like no like what well I
get a kick out of factly fights at 170 I
was standing next to him and I fight at
one
I'm 170 I'll fight once every day I just
stand up at once and they talk about
real real athletes but you talking about
real athletes and I was like you're how
are you 170 though sir cause your face
is what my knees you can fit in your
[ __ ] yeah he's a monster
yeah Indy not the same although I did
see our boy Matt Mitrione you did random
at me and Matt have a nice lunch
I love that you met had a nice lunch he
said let my boy Pat McAfee I know I know
Pat really well
oh you do yeah I would have done his
podcast I was asked to his podcast but I
got there was I got there on the day and
it was too much the best did you do his
podcast oh yeah comes out tomorrow great
guy great guy not a small man for a
punter kicker I uh he's like six foot
look much you looked your height no ok
now picturing that 6-foot cuz he goes
out there cuz we're talking about height
yeah and I go you're 510 is come on bro
shoes like that I you know I'm six foot
in these here's called timeless s61 you
know it goes ok use me I I don't even
give up six but really no great dude
good guy the best how do you know uh I
just work up from the same cloth he
retired they started doing a podcast
comedy were the same guy I not but he
the first I didn't know he was somebody
said Pat McAfee wants to you know he
runs the Midwest while your shows would
have sold out if he if he said if he put
one tween when it go see Bryan Callen
all your shows a sold-out really most
powerful men Midwest yeah Wow oh yeah
Pat McAfee I apologize I couldn't I
didn't have time by halftime I really
didn't because I got in on the day and
then they
Friday they wouldn't know Thursday and
they wanted me to do it I think that day
and then they said maybe we can do it
Friday the whole thing was weird and I
was like you could have skipped
everything you did out there and just
done his show and sold out every single
show and pay at its most profitable Wow
yeah laughter all right really really
good that McAfee
hey you know how it is Baba though when
you hear you're gonna do a podcast right
doing not if I know if I know if I know
if I'm aware I'm not saying if you
wanted to pop cause I go no I do podcast
and it's exhausting for me I just want
to sleep but but awesome I'm like if you
do a podcast I not podcast where's
chance of it coming out that means don't
think it's that night usually it's Kenya
7-5 here it's Billy and I'm starting a
podcast as radios dying here you know
I'm here with Bryan Callen pluck outs
come out next week yeah he has a podcast
he gets listeners that's why he's on
here I'm hoping you guys listen that
that's how I think that's what I that
was the judgment I'm a goof I wish you
would've texted me I should have texted
you
oh that's a monster not so talented -
didn't know that great studio set up did
not know that looks makes us look like
the poor kids well I apologize to Pat
matpat McAfee no I never heavy on its
lie big deal I have to call him back
he's funny man yeah so how well Pat
talked to me about it was great okay
setups great he's killing it I'm hung
out there he had a barber in his goddamn
studio it cut my hair
Pat loved the barber great guy and he'd
start laughing cuz he go barbers here I
went okay I didn't see me cuz you want
to hear Kelly go I'm out just let anyone
touch my hair and I got some question is
all right what do you gotta go is he
white he goes what does it matter go it
means everything here's what scenario it
means everything man I usually have you
what the fades I get or usually Nath
Nick thing so I'd rather have a black
guy cut my hair Mexicans in California
at my ear and he goes that's interesting
yeah he was he's black light fantastic
okay how's he carry no one else is here
he goes yeah Michael recently goes today
I go where's yeah he brings your eye
open that's a good haircut I'm down to
do it and they couldn't get over the
fact like whitey care what ethnicity is
like beacon listen man like stereotypes
exist for Russia now I'm sure that I'm
sure there's some great white barbers
bars haven't come across them usually
when I went
wanna fit now if I want a style the
stylist like if you're here's long yeah
white dudes are really good at that the
best ass I know the white dude who does
all these celebrities there I want a
fade though the whites aren't go to my
brother's okay so then why brothers
I go to my Bop dogs you got to check the
melanin someone's skin and I should've
done that say they do bro do you do the
same thing when you hem your jeans the
math Shem your taxes done you go to a
man correct a Jewish accountant correct
from a from runner race
I'm not gonna Japanese dude somebody
somebody is saying call my father my
father some guy who said something coach
it anti-semitic and my father goes huh
okay well I guess if you have a problem
choose if yeah but if but if the
government's coming after you the
government's coming after you want a
really good lawyer a couple Jewish
lawyers that might save your ass if
you've got a heart problem or a number
you got cancer and you want a really
good doctor they know they're really
doctor barrel couple Jewish doctors out
there might be able to save your life
yet so many he went down the whole
[ __ ] list it's like yeah and then
accountant yeah there's number of things
hmm Navy SEAL I know what yours Navy
SEAL half Jewish
interesting yeah Patton who thought it
was so ridiculous what ethnicity was uh
yeah well you know different cultures
tend to specialize in different things
and things yeah like if I know if I
gonna if I'm wearing pizza and it's like
the guys from Italy I know that the
dough's gonna be pretty [ __ ] good
well that's what they do
louis ck's got a hilarious joke he goes
I'm a little bit racist that's like if I
going if I go into a pizza midnight
place and it's for black women I'm like
okay no he goes he goes yeah he goes no
I'm like here's I'm not racist but he
was when I walk into a pizza joint
there's four black crows making pizza in
my Michael huh all right all right yeah
it's a good joke so true use if I go to
a convenience store late at night
there's a black kid with a hood on and
my mom like there's nothing wrong with
that you should not be nervous
there's no he's fine he's fine you're
fine you're gonna be fine yep it's so
yeah
we all think like that of course but
yeah path was great it's pattern
recognition had chicken with Matt
Mitrione some fried chicken
he said he's in shape right nice
fighting soon oh yes
fighting soon I think I'll bone he's
just a big dude just a raw boned big
just a big dude great scene here no
muscle definition and I hope he hears
that this is a big athletic just have
white guys like just trying to stay
Annapolis way by God um just think he's
awesome he's gone the mouth he's got a
cute mouth he and talk well yeah yeah
he's a cutie-pie
he's a cutie-pie I saw him and then dude
India would say it's what you'd look
when I was I was heisst but it was like
not that there's a problem with this at
all but I didn't know there's so many
black people in India
it was also black Expo weekend black
Expo weekend what does that mean bring
that up chin huh what's it sound like
black people
Mian Expo Oh even get you know Derek's
black nose I don't get it and went up
there one these police officers who's
black heels it's a black Expo dude black
people that's interesting next one oh
okay um so there was a it was it was
just interesting shows are great Club
was cool a lot of a lot of black people
in your audience yeah okay
it's great yeah I was like damn this is
news to me I thought India was all white
know my [ __ ] well and I said Milwaukee
was all white wrong so a lot of a lot of
black people came about first of all
black people had been there since the
days of slavery but a lot of black
people migrated from the south to the
north or of those states looking for
work to back in the day and then there
wasn't work good food good crowd some
great crowds Derrick got us kicked out
of an uber hilarious date
Oh hilarious he did oh yeah buster no
Derrick I hope my feature Buster's all
rode with it sir it was a derrick post
in he got you can't maneuver
well we got in is like like old school
black guy and this nice like Oldsmobile
like really nice and me and Osan get in
the back and there it goes again the
fret and here's the front like you know
how they stood all the way up like a
limo like [ __ ] Kenyon Martin thing
get in
spread his legs after idea when they do
that and so Derek goes giving goes all
she's gonna scoot it back the guy goes
damn man don't touch my chair there cuz
like I can't get in bro I think I have
to sit I can't fit in the back you know
front he's right but don't touch my
chair
Derek's like what alright so he gets in
his knees are up to his [ __ ] chanting
goes bro come on man be cool be cool let
me scoot it back and guy goes if you
want to touch my [ __ ] chair she got
an uber comfort and I'm like oh I go
whoa dude we're just we're literally
going five blocks not big deal so he
keeps going at because Derek goes dude
my back's that cuz he started to seize
up because we were walking so he's back
to Vegas
I'm just gonna back it up a little and
guy goes man if I tell you again
quit touch my [ __ ] chair and then
Derek has this this guy's these older
black dudes like cool he was like mr.
Joe cooling jumped in but then Derek
just switches that Memphis attitude we
got he got his mouth ha then Derek did
that well that other guy's not from
Memphis whatever Derek this plane goes
hold up hold up hold up he's not much
teach you something the past is the past
is the past is I don't know what
happened that triggered you so we got in
your card piss you off that's not I'm
hurting my [ __ ] back man we're just
going up the street and he keeps
shouting at the black guy in the black I
can tell he's been through some [ __ ] is
just going huh
he's his blood pressure did not raise it
Iseman and Derek keeps going I'm like
and I got my phone to film it I was like
well what's gonna happen here I wonder
DL world start didn't feel appropriate
right I'm just filming and then the
Derek's goes on this whole rant and all
this [ __ ] and the guy goes yeah yeah I
guess let me tell you something young
buck and Derek like goes what he knows
get the [ __ ] out my damn I want that
guy's awesome wow that was the end of
that yeah [ __ ] out my Derek didn't
Derek's just going cuz he get guys time
I was kids like man Derek site you know
he's just hurt Derek was hurt he's like
your kids don't love you you're broke
you take it out on me and the guy you
just in this one he's out of the car the
guy rolls down the wing goes my kids
don't love me I paid for all three of my
kids to go to college it was a nob
Brogan's like that
Joe kulfi was gone yeah here it goes
[ __ ] that guy went that goes awesome I
actually liked that guy
it was hilarious one time I was [ __ ]
uh we were like probably nineteen years
old
in college and all of us thought we were
kind of tough we were all taking
Taekwondo and wrestling and none of us
were big though none of us were like
we're just whatever so we're driving and
this guy this older dude probably 40
maybe 45 big and grizzled looking and we
we I guess he kind of cut us off a
little bit and then we pull up and we're
like hey watch where you're going and
the guy goes what he just turns up if he
goes what is where they and my buddy
goes watch where you're going you cut us
off and he goes he goes what are you
[ __ ] gonna do about you he was a
grown man yeah and he was really big and
I he just looked really rough and we
suddenly became children we were like
yeah whatever we want or something like
yeah we want and so he starts [ __ ]
driving along with us going you push
come on yeah he's looking for a fight I
was like this dude's got a gun a knife
or he's gonna kill us all anyway dude I
don't know his girl has pushed out like
little [ __ ] I'd like the 19 year old
[ __ ] we were I don't know what was
going on with Derek though because he
got in a conflict with that guy and then
we got doing this shows like 1:00 a.m.
and a cop told me he was a fan of the
shows and he goes hey brother where the
advice goes don't go out when you're
here this weekend he really goes it's
our number one weekend for crime do not
go out just go to you do your shows get
back and like all right no doubt like
y'all be fine man so we walk cross
because there's this like bar across the
street there's some I forget what is
going place open packed
we're walking there Derek has on a
Cincinnati Red Hat that he binds to see
what they was buy hats from whatever
city were in yeah you're the pro shops
like they're 14 and so he had a sin say
I read that on we're walking this is
like white frat dude with his girl not
that drunk either
pushes Derek and goes [ __ ] the Reds as
well what is happening right oh boy and
then deer goes what the [ __ ] and the guy
goes Cubs [ __ ] and I was like
but where are you from Chicago is no oil
what are you talking about but I guess
it's like Cubs laying around there yeah
you know using Chicago though but yeah
and then I told her I'm like you with me
on the road there's absolutely no
altercation no upside but I don't I
cannot be involved that he knew he knew
right away every time he apologized to
me I'm like dude it's not your fault I
guess an idiot but he's like dude I
would never get in a fight man I'm like
dude with me my background we can't do
because you have to be real prop what I
just don't need that like it's gonna be
problems man yeah but it was an
aggressive town dude well so anytime new
penny
I am on the road and this goes back for
as long any time I come out of a bar and
after midnight am i saying is nothing
good happens after midnight you know on
the street when people are milling about
after the bar that the board bar that
Blum drunk that's where guns knives and
pan fists how about is the [ __ ] out of
there how about Saturday night oh we had
a 6:00 a.m. flight so we'd leave at 4:00
a.m. so I know no one slept symp is a
terrible idea
I guess not doing that don't pop it
doesn't feel good pops too old you can't
do about all-nighters are too big to
sleep in those chair bit us all night
O'Brien so you put it down so we get
done at like 1:30 and I go let's not
walk this kind of dangerous let's take
an uber so Ian uber in the White Castle
open 24 hours Mike Katz White Castle we
pull up there first of all the weight
was probably three hours it looked like
goddamn Aerosmith concert and it's
packed it looks like if Trick Daddy
video I could the hot summer hot spot
cause I've seen twerking in the parking
lot I was like this seems awesome but I
can't wait this long for food our uber
drive guts bros there's this convenience
store right up the street I'll take you
there I remember Pat telling me goes
dude don't go a block north of my studio
because it's super seedy I go like why
he goes you get robbed at gunpoint
everyone hears hold it like it'd be a
real problem
meth addict everywhere because that's
why I got my studio G but you feel a one
block it you're in trouble
I remember the uber driver taking us and
I go others paths to do we're block
north of the aloes about poles 130 of
113 moines sir pull this convenience
store dude it looked like a scene out of
training day
the uber driver goes oh he was how
hunger you boys only not this hungry no
and just turn right back around right
get out of there oh let's get out here
yeah
I don't know anyone though I I don't do
any of that [ __ ]
I don't hang around I don't hang by I
don't hey like when that girl when that
when that drive when the cop was like
dude do shows and get out of it that's
my life do you know I don't hang I don't
I don't go to bar I just speakeasy with
the expensive drinks I hide in a corner
yeah I just go home yeah or I'll find
somewhere away from the place and get
food and just chill especially if Jays
with me yeah I told you we got a bomb
threat in India right no they're gonna
cancel the shows what I didn't tell you
guys I don't get this did you know this
Jen yeah got a bomb threat what
and the ND police like world they were
actually really on it were they worried
you were gonna mom come on that's a good
burn dude
how weird is that done what do you mean
yeah and then he plays like should we
cancel the shows they they called in a
bomb threat into the mall that you were
nope
sent me the bump they're like some
morons they sent you a bomb throwing up
they said we're gonna bomb because you
were there mm-hmm that doesn't make
sense that's a crazy I should have ever
heard
like we said sent to the authorities I
take suggesting it's simple authorities
so wait so did they call the club oh
yeah because but but the police were on
it the club they're like this our
busiest weekend Eve anyway so we have 70
cops literally in that vicinity
someone's gonna be watching at all times
you're good I was like God please don't
let me die in Indy with these front of
these crowds some domestic terrorists
some [ __ ] what can you do well then a
bomb threat you ever hear our language
you know I respond back to them that
dude please don't blow up the
Indianapolis helium they those people
just come for a comedy show or if you
really have a problem just meet me in
the parking lot let's see how it goes
for you there you go yeah there you go
give him a little shove around you know
you do love use a bomb you give that
domestic terrorist a little slap around
you go like this you do the jorge mazda
at all yeah see in a parking lot peace
minor
you might get slapped up i don't like
you you like it slapped up now here's a
bomb though you know well so that's why
you got all braai
- oh he's nice what's the wires elizy
clip the wires no he's not he's got a
bomb and I come and I go I got this
pliers I clip the wires my my or I take
my fingers as the fuse is going and I go
you like cut the red cut the red do it
be yeah I have a son who knows bombs I
figures it out what's up now hold on
dangerous Mouse in the house okay
Hasan those bombs maybe right like I cut
my hair alright okay I'm not gonna touch
that one but you know you never know
don't touch the red wire don't touch the
red wire and then give him us then slap
him up oh do you shouldn't touch what
anything john jones related that would
be another thing now now you cook a
little heat because you said that well
Jamie as cinnamon rolls crimes joking
around
yeah it's not that come on you're like
did anybody take a look at that her name
is I thought that was funny her name is
cinnamon you just being silly
God she is this it was like how do you
she's a stripper it's an offensive tweet
how dare you she's not even a stripper
she just works there like well strip
club battery well here's my thing like
so with this it's like oh this is all
I'm saying
I just need more facts before we should
[ __ ] on whether it's John Jones Kevin
Spacey Bryan Callen Joe Rogan Theo von
if some came out whoever it is I know
John has check your background who and
rightfully so but whoever it is I'm not
gonna tell the UF's I'm not gonna tweet
you see you've got to get rid of guys
Chris should be over because a waitress
at a strip club going well that goes by
a fake name says he choked her there's
no video there's no evidence it's four
months later there's witness over there
four months later there's no video
serving see yeah and also here's a very
carefully go thing Brian when she came
up you know it's John Jones I'm fun at
the strip club he slaps her I guess in
the [ __ ] she goes well if you want to
do that that's a hundred dollars sir so
I'll she she entertained it yeah so
that's what we're dealing with here all
I'm saying the girl said he'd been
serving his offense for the duration of
their evening at the club the
starfighter reportedly request to dance
from her but she declared
five she was only away she's not a
stripper then she claimed Jones took
things up a notch and pulled her to his
lap he then began kissing her neck when
she later went to the bar to get shots
for his group Jones allegedly struck up
snug snuck up behind her and put her in
a tight rear naked chokehold
the woman has gaped from the hole though
she escaped but then Jones allegedly can
picked her up off the ground and turned
her around in the air and was
roughhousing with her she let her told
the police it felt like a wrestling
match nothing sexual hmm he turned
around yeah he was yeah but this was he
became that she said John Jones placed
her down by the bar and slapped her
[ __ ] the woman said she told Jones not
to touch her in that fashion but if you
wanted to hit the pay for it if he was
gonna smack her he needed to pay her
$100 which she told John Hunt twice then
she told the police I think John Jones
is a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
it is a bit particularly that the club
question would have a mayor hunter
dollar feet for the patrons become
violent with the staff okay
so first of all first of all John lahum
percent shouldn't be mean destruction
being stripped dude with your check it
back crazy and if you are gonna go there
let's not do any of this yeah that's not
do any of that but he shall lose a
career over this I'm I'm not ready just
throw them under the [ __ ] bus with
these facts than I have well I don't
know
what the question is there's got to be
video surveillance right this guy that's
what we've been at some strip clubs yeah
any strip club there's always video yeah
now there's no video in the boom-boom
room there's no video in there that's
where everyone goes the boom-boom room
for that VIP experience yeah but there's
where he's out where they're saying the
bar there's cameras show me the footage
right show with the footage yeah uh I
think what you're saying is that there's
an allegation and it's not appropriate
this [ __ ] if he did all this stuff
that's a problem but I don't condone any
enero but at the same time I'd like to
see some evidence that's all you're
saying and is it is it that bad I went
hold up we're gonna crucify John Jones
who's done some horrible things is it is
it surprising they do this No
but am I gonna crucify this guy over a
waitress at a strip club who they don't
have any other evidence no it's a
wait-and-see thing right you got to be
like wait hold on before we throw them
under the bus and that's what I'm said
that's all I'm saying because the media
wants to [ __ ] on him I'm not defending
him but we do know this could be any but
we do live in an environment where we're
an accusation or two can can actually
cause you to lose your job now let me
tell you this Neil deGrasse Tyson we've
seen that all this that does those
allegations were unbelievable and have
you have you seen a ride up show have
you seen a ride up we're song does
actually this was all [ __ ] never see
me now have you clicked on that now now
now let's say nothing comes of this do
you think ESPN and all these [ __ ]
journalists gonna write actually John
they do anything just in the strip club
I'm fine
this girl's John's a tough guy to defend
right so John I'm not defending John I'm
defending anybody yeah yeah that's I
think you're saying let's be careful but
I'll tell you what anything John Justin
touch he has so many haters well just
don't come people are coming out to me
and I was like what now hold up hold up
hold up this could be literally anybody
yeah I'm just saying for a strip club
waitress to make these claims and
there's no other key witnesses in a
crowded strip club or a video I'm not
ready to say John should lose his job
that's all whether he's a fighter
it's good if they like Starbucks I don't
care it would be good if there were
corroborating like witnesses and video
I'd like to see see what you're asking
for us can I see some evidence before we
throat destroy his destroy his career
again but here's the other thing if you
show me video and those things are true
get him the [ __ ] out well I have zero
zero like if you know if he did all that
as he did all that see yeah we can't
happen yeah but I'm not without any
evidence without just taking a strip
club
waitresses word on it with no other
evidence yeah in once and would she be
making Iowa Iowa same thing would she be
making this claim as if his name was
Steve Jones yeah I don't know I think
that the I think that the main thing is
we do have to have evidence before we
did we throw somebody under the bus
and I think if you don't just remember
if you live in that world
you're next you're next because people
there are plenty of people that will do
whatever they can to get you out of the
way but but I still think with the
internet everyone's like yes yeah um
whoa whoa chill do yeah I know you guys
need something to do with your lives and
the hate there like there's this hate
club and they want to direct the
attention towards that it's like dude
but also at least point your gun at
something worthwhile but also John of
course don't be in strip clubs and also
I think a lot of people are reacting to
the fact that he did hit a pregnant
woman in a car and ran away and then
came back and got his cash okay and
broke her arm there's so many things
where we're all like dude I
I'm not I know again I'm not the person
that's horrible sure you're defending
the principle yes could be John the [ __ ]
could be Tom Brady which I think it's
been Shawn don't care what I'm saying
let's say those accusations came out at
chin let's say happen to my girl let's
say my girl was like hey man and let's
say she was the the the strip club
waitress like hey I came in John did all
this even know Micra I'm like is anyone
else see it you have any video your
pictures just cuz you want to yeah my
who need all like what are we gonna do
need who I saw at the club like you tell
me that PAC strip club no one else saw
it and all those people you think all's
people loved John Jones people can't
want to see Jon Jones burn man yeah so
you tell me no one else saw this I don't
know man well it's not I don't know at
the bottom line is you need all that you
have to have got to something you have
to say so there's no evidence is as
surfaced no if anything I think Jones's
team said that they have people like
waitresses and whatever that are
witnesses that want his side that's
interesting and but don't boo hmm I
would imagine the club would have maybe
that videotape erases after a short
period of time this is four months later
this happened four months ago and now
the surface
April April so what and she filed a
complaint now I guess so he found out
through a news agency that something
happened were huh yeah you had to pay a
fee because if something happened here's
my other thing like a two hundred other
for you I don't think anything's gonna
come from come of this and and here's my
a this my problem with the media how
many people are gonna write that nothing
came from this and that grows full of
[ __ ] they won't not one and yet all you
[ __ ] are throwing everyone under the
bus without any real evidence
that was the point in my tweet this is
going on all the time that's what I'm
saying b-but whether it's John John
Jones is in my wheelhouse right yeah
he's in he's in what I do so when it's
whether it's John whether it was Conor
McGregor whether it was Chris Weidman
Brian Bader
named Eenie fighter I would have said
the same thing but the reason John you
so much hate is because his checkered
past
yes but I'm saying take your blindness
hate away from John he might trigger in
so many ways you hate him for all those
things take that away if it was just a
regular dude we wouldn't be like that
yes they're just doing it because
there's what you can't do well um
there's so much of that that goes on
like people were very quick to interpret
something and label it and I think
that's always a mistake my problem is
like this [ __ ] culture we live in a
woman and really it's the extreme right
even with politics like the the the 1%
kind of sway the nerve online which
isn't real why the voting is real I
didn't think that what Trump said about
go back to your countries you came from
III didn't think that was racist I
thought that was more um that's not the
definition of racism that might have
been xenophobic that might have been
nationalists kind of sentimental but
racist is a stretch and then media kept
saying what he said was racist and they
keep saying it and it's a racist tweed
racist tweet and in everybody use this
word so often so often and in fact
losing its me to remember that deed this
country voted in a black president and
in and he won he won the whitest States
you got to remember that he won the
whitest states twice so so when we start
with throwing this word around that in a
very strong way the woman who got the
woman the Chinese woman she's Chinese
ethnically Chinese she was Miss what was
it Meredith said there was everything
again I please Michigan says there was a
thing said try on a hit job trying a hit
job okay his job is you know what that
is if you're the helm and she said and
she said all she tweeted was oh so I
have to try I have to try and I've had
jobs to see what it's like to be
oppressed under Islam okay that's her
point of view as a woman I'm not gonna
wear a veil she finds it offensive that
seems to be not radical as an American
woman she's like I don't want to wear
that I consider it offense
if I told you to wear a veil so she's
like I don't want to do that and you're
telling me to do that because I guess
then she said halt and let me read this
piece no she goes there is a try a job
on booth out my college campus so you're
telling me that's now just a fashion
accessory not a religious thing or are
you just trying to get women to use to
being oppressed under Islam it's just a
plan with that it's something she put do
you know the majority of black deaths
are caused by other blacks fix the
problems with your own committee before
blaming others that's a strong thing to
say but but it's her point of view and
they stress chip and let me just read
you something I one thing I'm not
running yeah so my my friends back he
was just his mother was shot yeah and
his and he was shot and he's in the
hospital now and I want to just read you
what a black what a black leader in that
community said this was a black leader
who said this in the community in
Florida and they found I was three young
black men okay caught two and one is it
large and he said elderly woman this is
a black leader in the community elder
woman seven years old shot to death
during violent home invasion this is my
friend she used to come to my shows all
the time and I she's Abby was a
beautiful lovely lady she was retired
secretary that worked at Miami Edison
okay once again young black men
attacking and killing the most
vulnerable in our community if you see
the other suspect turn his ass in now
that's that's a that's a black man of
that community and he has a right to say
that he's like he's he's heartbroken
he's fed up it there are a lot of
problems in community data I'm not a
sociologist I'm not gonna go into it so
this is a Chinese woman who said
something of her own point of view that
this this black man of this community
said it's a point of view you can have
an argument about it you can find it
offensive and everything else but to
strip her of her [ __ ] title and call
her racist is is not fair it's not true
it's not fair maybe but just because you
express a point of view and you're
trying to you're trying to get the truth
out there so we can address real
problems doesn't make you a racist she's
[ __ ] Chinese if this is my thing
about let's say and we don't know the
facts maybe just come out John did this
but let's go back to that stripper let's
say no this really happened she's
actually taken away from the real
movement and real domestic violence and
real accusers you're actually heard of a
movement that was my mess like me yes
there's
real [ __ ] happen can you go back all
Sony call her racist that's awesome
we'll show you real racist right in red
and look at how the media frames its
Miss Michigan loses crowd because of
racist Islamophobic tweets so they've
already said they've decided it's a
racist tweet
do you understand how they they frame it
the rude you're already you're already
framing it that way so it the New York
toad York Times The Washington Post they
use this language and you don't even
have a chance to it's like I wasn't I
didn't mean it to be racist you know the
truth is that is that is the truth that
that that the majority of black deaths
are caused by other black people effect
yes and that's a tragedy
I thought violent death is so what if we
know that's the problem let's get that
out there and say that I love them what
solve the problem why is it triggering
for people because probably the truth if
you're triggered by something there's
something going on yeah yeah yeah but I
have you talked to black people in that
community they'll agree with you okay
well white people may kiss me and
misfire and kid yeah I thought the [ __ ]
is that tassel on her right now she's an
avid Trump supporter so I said okay
she's already a target and it's C hot oh
yeah she's also been dreaming of that
Michigan watch because I'm serving a
views that that's really what it is you
she has conservative arses yes yeah
she's a very smart yeah be first before
blaming others so do you say but she
gets a lot of support could be seen as
offensive you know this tweet was sunny
in response to another person talking
about how all blacks are all cops are
bad people that they kill innocent black
people and I think that you should just
put a blank it's a man over all cops you
know again read full tweets and context
to make sure to Phyllis to see the full
story yeah but I mean I guess your point
did you know the majority of black
deaths are caused by other blacks what's
your point it's a step if a statistics
thing you can find out on FBI website
this is all backed up by so Texas and
fax I think it's really really awful how
the left thinks that statistics and
facts are racist so I don't think
anything I said was remotely wrong I
stand by every tweet that I post there's
there's so many bad things happening
she's too young she's too young to
articulate unfortunately all right never
mind
but either way she's being grilled force
work enik a point of view and an opinion
and if you
don't tow the line like this dummy to
the left is this [ __ ] this journalist
a pseudo journalist company whatever her
name is less CNN she's no I'd love she
see n n so hilariously liberal and so
[ __ ] intellectually bankrupt too bad
I wasn't there so I could just you know
you should represent her I just did I
would like to ask this dummy echo of me
at fight you and her all right
you attacked him at okay you guys are
because I won't defeat this [ __ ] or both
you alright well cat would be to grab
one touch ago gotta be tough yes it's
not how you start oh yeah
are you talking about how thing out we
have no side very clear toxic very quick
everyone socks it yeah very Montecito
Tom Mabel you're a racist label you a
homophobe but I give you a Tran the
majority of American if you ask people
are those race sale right now no you go
online psycho my God's the end of the
world right now
will you go to people like real people
like now I don't give a [ __ ] I'll go to
work nobody sign up get out of here but
these troublemakers the media makes
money off of highlight like babe I
understand why the media like CNN loses
their credibility I really do what what
are you what are you guys doing they're
in the business of making money and
ratings they're not in the business of
truth no they're just not they want
clickbait they want contract agreements
this way Colin Jordan Peterson erases
that's what get some views though bro
conjure Dan Peterson an alright guy
calling Joe Rogan an alright guy [ __ ]
you guys you're just so stupid they're
just not you know what it is they're not
that smart then I just change the way
they do business because they that's the
way the clicks now yeah it's it's just a
shame crazy hey it really is and I like
Anderson Cooper some tile oven Cooper
you know you're see the picture of him
when he says he's in the flood and it's
like dry all around him but he decided
to step in the puddle he's up to his
knees in it oh my god really well you
know do the shot me the shot you see it
well it shows two kids like looking at
them and it's like in this giant river
he's like the flooding is terrible know
these kids are literally like what the
[ __ ] well that's all I guess that's all
out what you know just do a stream flood
pick right there it is
comparison like that the two guys are up
there yes see goes the deepest part I
miss deep for sure
yeah good Ram 41% mm-hmm they are down
I think his his show doesn't do well at
all that I got that Trump guy who is on
there goes your ratings are terrible you
know that did you hear him he goes this
is why he was so funny because you're
raining your ratings are terrible you
you're just you're in the dumps I could
he could something about Trump could
tweet something and it gets more views
than you on your best day he was before
even saying an Anderson he was like yeah
and this is why because you just you're
not telling the truth ever and Americans
can see it they smell it it was so funny
would get it men and people are and when
you start calling this country racist
and you start saying that there are
races for sure but the real racists like
that ain't be a little bit ruin it for
burning carefully [ __ ] and [ __ ] on
fire definitely races that racist like
dude give us a bad name that most
Americans are like [ __ ] I've traveled
you and I travel to my travel I know to
red states I know how people are they're
not you're being unfair you just aren't
it's not true this to me cuz when you go
to the Midwest and their view on Trump's
different than ours like you're certain
like a Trump joke here will hit
different than yeah there yeah that's
your fans yeah well well again there's
reason why you won you forget again
y'all damn because under eight years ago
they didn't have a lot they weren't
making a lot of money yeah it comes down
to the economy it doesn't come down to
the horse can do I have money or not I
need money and the economy is doing well
endure I'm speaking money I saw a lion
king yes how was it it's great scale
1-10 because I heard great CGI that's a
thing short on emotion the graphics
ridiculous some things just still got a
toast or something just got to leave
alone yeah I said that I told you in
this on blows but I said it's like
watching the graphics are so real like
holy that's a real line talking another
line and sing it but it's like watching
National Geographic but then they just
bust out in music in harmonies it
doesn't work it just it
does it's so [ __ ] real but then
they're singing damn look at that is
that scarf yeah
it looks so [ __ ] every looks so real
yeah do you see ken yeah what do you
think mmm
I think the music was great so GI was
great but I just it was better as an
animation I even closed
yeah I was so bored during my son was
bored to tears took tears he hated it
and with then seth rogen I feel like
stole them still the movie the guy who
did - moans Timon and Pumbaa were
amazing mm-hmm
but it's just like like scar in the
cartoon when he's singing it's like kind
of scaring they have that green like
flames behind him well there's not that
now because naturally graphic it seemed
singing who did he's on a rock cars
voice oh it used to be Jeremy Hans Seth
Rogen so good but whose scars voice you
see the whole cast I you know I Kat I
know this is it not a popular opinion I
didn't like Beyonce in it
I thought her music was terrible yeah
dad didn't feel oh he's great she we'd
all oh he was so good he gets Carla let
me hear it
scars it's great huh scar was the best
character in that well I thought Seth
Rogen was the best but I chief aura
mm he was good yeah he was really good
but the mostly English yeah yeah but the
movie is uh I don't know that's uh it's
it I thought jungle book and what's the
other one that allowed it was better
mm-hmm I think they could have done
without this one yeah this dummy you
know something's just don't need to be
redone I can't wait for Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood but you got a seat comes
out Thursday this was a huge twist and
it's gonna ruin it they say so you got
to see it before everyone starts
snitching really I'm see ya Thursday not
coming there I can't wait to see it I'll
be in Montreal I think my shows when is
my show in Montreal Friday damn
well this him singing on the mountaintop
all but just for you guys see this
sounds cool here cuz sounds like cartoon
but no it's a real line on a rock it's
not barely moving like what the [ __ ] is
happening right now just it just missed
and I think most people agree with us
yeah it's not like it did well at the
box office like biggest July ever looks
like not a great mmm reviews yeah
wanna watch it it was okay I couldn't
wait for it to end really no huh-uh
you think you've called the pack out
fight call it well done I guess the Hans
makers head pack has the favorite I said
just Thurmond didn't look great man his
last fights too much of a jump Pacquiao
moves at 40 years old like he was moving
at 30 crazy smaller guy I just think
yeah it just does a bad match for
Thurman
yeah ya know what do you do it why why
why did you say that but he look like
crap he took two years off he's been
doing this thing you can tell he's kind
of like got married to the dying piece
girl landed a lot of shots though he
landed more shots yeah but he didn't you
know Pat Joe had the knockdown which was
the difference but decision yeah
God he's so good also taking account to
like yeah remember boxing so goddamn
crooked Pacquiao is good for the sport
yeah if it's a close decision I think
they want Keith Thurman Apache I don't
want Pacquiao you think if Canelo goes
to close decision like Canelo triple G
Pat you know you name any guy can't [ __ ]
caused more damage than I would I gave
it to him you know I gave it to him
phenomenal a thermos still a great
fighter right a definition of a great
fighter knock him down gets back up
still takes it Stubb finish this
stronger than he started all that stuff
oh yeah that's one of the best
yeah real champion yeah yeah but what do
you do you Thurman Floyd now ah pack
halfway
yeah pack yeah what well I mean yeah you
wanna see it because I want to see if
that shoulder situation was real I mean
they're older is [ __ ] no but yeah but
Pacquiao looks as fast as he ever did
well not let's no definitely not he's
good not amazing if you get older yeah
that's what happens at 40 but you know
he's got it you may see the exact same
thing with Floyd what's so good I think
Floyd has a flat and competive Bucks
match in a long time
yeah a long time spot caught a right
different animal yeah and thought that
Takashi whatever kid in Japan doesn't
get tired maybe he should retire I think
you should stay retired is there talk of
him coming oh yeah oh yeah how do % and
you know he wants to you know he's gonna
I don't know if he does I think he wants
the paycheck and the challenge right I
don't know it would definitely be a
challenge just for you doesn't fun a
long last time back y'all look good I
bet you Floyd still practicing though oh
yeah well you should repost this video
all the time him working out he's even
shaped such a badass I would watch it
just don't charge me the hundred dollars
that's [ __ ] yeah he's just I get
paid I'm a huge dick me too buddy let me
help you out alright you want to cross
swords yeah we'll be back
the thing about me is I'm about
performance I'm about lifestyle I'm
about premium activities I'm about
wearing hot stuff you're gonna go the
mall buy a bunch of stuff and look sweet
while you're working as you ask I'm not
because I want science engineer for
unparalleled quality I know dude comfort
yeah but you I need call you any comfort
any durability and yes female you guy on
the go
some say I go okay so does it matter if
you're training with gym doesn't matter
jumping on international flights what
you do on the plane maybe just uh you
know this guy wants to just look sweet
in my house and for my kid yeah there
you go
we'll give out my wrong talking about
Rho and E Y on you right now for real
some of the best-looking clothing some
of the best-looking like athletic gear
it's crazy yeah but do everything I
didn't they I think I saw you in the
commuter collection will they just drop
that it's warrants alternative to
everyday work we're offering everything
from pants polos shorts shirts
lightweight comfortable also wrinkle
free don't be all wrinkly I do that I
travel I want to look good when I'm
sitting on a plane I mean I get up and
out of the you look like a bum no I look
like a bum on a plane don't look like
bum at home don't bum when you're
working out get room go Tyrone Rho and
EECOM slash fighter today use promo code
fight
get 20% off your first purchase that's
rh o n EECOM slash fighter promo code
fight over 20% off i know people in the
clothing business who say no what's some
of the best quality you can get doesn't
get better than this
that's a fact rom.com slash fighter
actually I've had some people reach out
to tell me that this better help app
this better help service I should say is
has been very helpful you have licensed
counselors that will actually help you
with your mental health therapist
therapist if a therapist that you have
whenever you you can start communicating
right now under 24 hours it's not Christ
slice not self help it's professional
counseling done securely online there's
there's a broad range of expertise to
help you guys out whatever you need
some of those successful people in the
world talk to therapists like Ryan Calif
or that you can start communicating
under in under 24 hours and let's be
honest sometimes you need somebody to
talk to his non-judgmental is not a
friend and who's a professional know
they know what they're doing
exactly I found immense benefit from
this man it's fun as well I think it's a
good time I look forward to it and the
services available worldwide log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor you get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
what's the best part is be it's
affordable it's more affordable and
traditional going into a place and
sitting down face to face offline
counseling can be very expensive there's
financial aid even available visit
better help calm slash fighter and join
the over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional and you guys
the tea fat k army back hair on you guys
get 10% off your first month at better
help calm slash finer if you guys using
keep blowing this up saying how much it
helps I'm gonna freak out I'm gonna bust
better help calm slash fighter it is
very helpful let's do them got done
another car wreck well I did not another
I was at a full complete stop when a
seemingly nice Armenian family didn't
pay attention and
hit the back of my car the rear end you
they rear-ended me I was at a full stop
again though that's the thing that's why
that's how the last one happened
yes I was at a full stop you said it
wasn't my fault if it was my fault trust
me I'd say it I would admit to it and
just blame it on being an Asian woman
but in the last you just weren't my her
insurance is like Jesus Christ man
oh my god it was so annoyed was the
damage it really wasn't bad I was
driving my grandparents minivan at the
time so it just took your grandparents
in a minivan yeah I actually kind of
love it on a lot of room a lot of room
kind of fantasize about having a not
have been like a van that has everything
I needed and weaponry water lentils you
know and dude yeah I don't do they still
make vans like new they can buy you
definitely used like you know you can
get these badass fans that have like
everything in them friends going all
over no specifics going across the
country in a van that's a kick-ass van
the 4x4 ones are awesome too like like
it's almost like you can sleep in it's
like a it's like also like a lake
Thomson's camper vans like yeah like
that that's a badass van they got some
really cool ones oh yeah I like that one
turtle now sprint the Mercedes like
those sprinters are what the that's what
I like that were lot of bands use those
down to the giant bus let me see the
center that's I like these a lot
that's what Phillip Rivers has a knee
that's a core van system setup what is
that that's a spread sprinter I like
sprinters look at that thing so let me
see the inside of a sprinter I don't
feel like death or your five do you know
what if I want to just go sometimes you
ever go like this I'm gonna ride in a
sprinter yeah you even dalam up inside
that's what bands like slippers are use
it now they're not really in the big
tour where where do they where do you
sleep
I think it's just for touring just
rhetoric then they go to a house a
little bed in some of them but that's
nothing look you see Phillip Rivers I
don't know if they have it on there
Philip Rivers cuz he still lives in
Orange County of his team moved to LA so
his whole family is like 19,000 kids so
they stationed in Orange County sandy or
at San Diego then he dries
this here it is huh but go back to the
inside that's cool man
you might be one of these in our Cobra
it says that like it's Philip Rivers
still playing right there there it is is
he still playing how dare you he's so
awesome
how long's even so he'd watch he watches
film for the you know it's like a
two-hour drive he just studies film and
look at that [ __ ] thing so sick you
can click on any of those Jim that's
what was an SUV that's gonna run me 204
oh that ate all that stuff why would you
have that
what film rate you know what cuz I
watched film they should watch porn
there it is [ __ ] yeah they don't see any
go but trains in LA makes that commute
why just a savage daddy's awesome yeah I
really want I want a sprinter get one
dude but I need I need I want I want
what if I before ok get me some of the
get sprinter for camping that's what I
want to see I don't they're not for
camping be you you want a camper
I want a camping man I want a camper
yeah you want RV there's some cool IVs
there you got day you go I'm gonna now
I'm gonna go down that rabbit hole
130,000 G's 4x4 to now you want to
straight camp with you on an RV dude
okay I wanna Rocky yeah this is so much
there's I mean there's so big it's like
there you go
that's a Catholic spur now huh kitchen
sink I don't know what we'd do with it
be kind of cool
Ed's driver I get sick in cars man I
can't watch greens or TVs or anything
yeah it's a small you know there's
there's a big YouTube thing now with van
life and they usually have hot chicks
that live in vans and they get tons and
tons of views
oh really yeah it was just so let's talk
about their vans that they live in and
just hot chick there's something by the
river you can [ __ ] I find it hot very
[ __ ] a busy road you can just like to
park and Rodeo Drive and get get down
with your tinted windows and you're
looking at people walk by us your
[ __ ] but you can do that you know
that's not
not with yeah not something you can
stand up in bro yeah the van thing
doesn't do it for me man
no okay hmm there you go
well that guy like the best mountain
climber in the world lived in this but
yes he did
I haven't still haven't seen for you so
uh yeah this is like cluttered there's
not that does that water
what'd you guys do this weekend for
woody Kermit's what you do cat um I went
to go watch Lion King um I got a win
mm-hmm I got a rental car uh ravening
truck right now it looks dope girls that
drive trucks pretty hot I want a ring
later though yeah
you look sweet in the Jeep I just don't
know if I should do it
put the top down you sick you know that
make regular trucks Oh the gladiator is
that what's called I think it's like
yeah she makes her growl got you a lot
of that car a great car looks so stupid
you're not feeling that no no that looks
bad oh I like that's not a road it'd
look cool
oh no you want to Jeep you yeah I see
you like it it looks cool no either
yours or a Jeep no it's all hanging off
the side the doors off isn't the issue
it's the fact that it's like a Franken
truck it's a mini truck that the on top
looks better I think they look cool if
you want to get ready and get busy yeah
yeah right gonna [ __ ] journey yeah
she and what do you do besides put this
through remember so the studio sting um
Little Tokyo I did like a miniature food
crawl type of thing in the old Tokyo
would you go it a couple friends really
good no what is she doing she's uh she's
waiting for us to go singing again what
do we know us mean her you guys are
welcome to come yeah yeah I'll come yeah
I would sing don't wanna cause my eyes
that everyone sings know what would they
do
yeah that's hard to sing yeah but people
suck so do you and I miss you babe not
letting the move
oh do somebody so yeah yeah
I don't have nothing so I don't know
even tough all right give us some
current events all right first one
Kirino a 35 year old man rushed to his
mother's apartment building after his
sister called saying that it was on fire
he got there and he wanted to make sure
that his mom was okay because she's
disabled and she's bedridden but when he
got there the police officers wouldn't
let him go up the stairs and the
elevators were shut down so he took it
upon himself to scale the building to
the 15th floor where she lives
[ __ ] and she was actually out on the
patio space with her boyfriend she was
fine the fire was contained at that time
and didn't reach her unit so he then
proceeded to climb back down god damn
was so good at climbing
dude what I know she say that because
the door was locked he had to climb dude
scared that's cute that's crazy
reaching his mom she was fine she's like
we doing apart the newest quote was me
coming down I actually climbed up cuz
they saying she was trapped his mom teen
floor when he saw that his mom was in
need adrenaline took over well when I
grabbed the gate at the top of the gate
it was a Ledge and then it was gonna
step on the ledge and then what a bad
idea
stomach down what about us yeah hey
media don't shine bright [ __ ] lights
on him so concentration yeah he was
supposed to be arrested when he got down
and that's why he expected but police
officers they were cool about it they're
like no thank you
you're all go bomb it was your mom yeah
cool so uh now he's just going about his
day he's deemed a hero in this community
now it's cool
shut up to Philly what else get to Cass
so have you guys seen this clip there is
a comedian her name is I believe Dena
know so she makes a joke on Comedy
Central's night at the Comedy Cellar
about the rapper xxx 10th AC on she sent
some [ __ ] man yeah he's very beloved
within the hip-hop community but he's
also very controversial because he was
known in the past you have had like
there were allegations never confirmed
of him beating his pregnant girlfriend
at the time and abusing other women but
I'll try to be funny here is he the one
who passed away yes he is the one who
know what had done yes okay he died
because he went to go buy a car he had
$50,000 on him the people who murdered
him in Miami yes in Myakka Ferrari or
something yeah it's just a young guy who
wanted to go get a car had a lot of cash
on hand robbed got robbed and he died so
this comic made on economy central right
mm-hmm cuz I saw so many comics tweeted
out about it and I didn't understand
what they're talking about so this is
the joke and I guess people were like
Comedy Central how do you how do you not
back up this comic you know like you
know comedy should have no limits well
how'd you not back her up in County
senator have to come and go we didn't
pull the thing she pulled it she's
getting death threats yeah Tommy Sam's
going we didn't do anything so let me
see what's going on here do you have all
the low energy in the world what's going
on there babe I'm doing some coffee
wake up bro listening power sleep I was
just listening go he's a he's a rapper
who was murdered he's dead now um he was
he was shot he was on his way to buy a
car with $50,000 in cash and somebody
shot him and took the money which is
very tragic I think also it would be a
very good venmo commercial
that's good joke it's not a bad joke
that's the first thing I thought that's
how problems good comments that's it oh
he has a very large fan base a lot of
people really loved him and that's why I
get so much these are people just trying
to put known a community and no hobbies
hold on other comics went after Oh some
other comic went after and people just
[ __ ] they find out real comics um that's
what it yeah if they're with comics
they're not they're not there's no
that's a good joke sorry that's
hilarious joke but unfortunately she is
getting death threats she ended up um
pooling that joke and she says that
she's never gonna say it what's her name
like inchi Natasha
there's stay strong and [ __ ] all these
dummies that was a good joke and you're
a good comic most most be mean most
people had everyone most comments are to
thing it yeah it is a good video super
[ __ ] advent mouth you know I mean
she's not saying it's very tragic and it
is and of course again this this [ __ ]
culture look at this passage I cancel
Comedy Central Deena Hoffman who are
thinking xx whatever the [ __ ] his name
is being robbed and murdered it's funny
oh my god
you guys you guys are such let's do that
then let's [ __ ] do it
[ __ ] shut up he's just got baby he's
got young fans who are heartbroken that
he died and I get it and they're there
in a group and they get to gang up and
it put brings you together
he will make fun of abortion at 11:00
Hitler cancer AIDS racism and everything
else under the Sun but X is where the
line is drawn its stand-up comedy all
subjects are fair game correct then this
little point puts X was a huge
inspiration to a whole generation it
made a huge impact he's trying to change
the world and touch so many people
that's why alright okay dude you're
young and extreme and it's fine alright
next one that's so interesting I saw so
many comics beat jump but I didn't know
what's going on funny - am I like you so
a Massachusetts Police Department
released a statement on their Facebook
page saying folks due to the extreme he
were asking anyone thinking of doing
criminal activity to hold off until
Monday it is straight up
as soccer balls out here conducting
criminal activity in this extreme heat
is next-level henchmen status and also
very dangerous stay home blast the AC
bench stranger things season three play
with the face app practice karate in
your basement we will all meet again on
Monday when it's cooler sincerely the
Popo very good PS please no spoiler
alerts we're fit we're just finishing
season two very funny
well done brain tree please support
department where's that at Master Chief
said that finding [ __ ] I guess crime
goes up as a good topic so you have it
irritated at this summer time people in
Chicago were people outside but they're
also entertained no a/c or get a little
crazy that's in fact so hilarious Bravo
Braintree Police Department funny we
will meet again on my night and it's
cool that so good dude what else you got
alright this one this is rumors some
friends sent me this Eddie Murphy is
apparently close to a 70 million dollar
stand-up deal with Netflix sale yeah did
you see him on the commands and cars
getting coffee huh cycles comeback yeah
he's amazing
and if you I think who was it it was uh
Oh Chris Rock and sick in the head on
Judd Apatow's book he talks about Eddie
more their trauma Eddie Murphy and he
does four big fights he always has
people over the house the biggest of the
basic comics overs house and they say
Eddie Murphy just destroy destroy
yeah-oh destroys [ __ ] so Eddie Murphy
here's a thing be because you know
here's I'm sure he's gonna do up he
hasn't been on the circuit
he hasn't been in a while so I'm curious
cuz like Ellen hasn't been going around
doing front and that she does especial
is just a little different right
apparently he's always hi
apparently always hi always always hi so
I don't know and he that when he was
what he was he wasn't so bein seen see
what weed does to his brain and what
he's doing I don't know let's say yeah
at Eddie Murphy though he's aware of the
kind of the bar that he said so I he
wouldn't come back
it was a bad he said he has to practice
well not any money no he told Jerry
Seinfeld he's like oh he was I'm going
to go to clubs like guarantees that the
Comedy Store
you gotta go that's what I mean you got
you've got a practice that's awesome
yeah Eddie Murphy Wow
another rumors this is more realistic
though kanye west's thinking of doing a
star wars-themed low-income housing
project my Star Wars thing because it
will be looking like exactly what these
things are
you'd be underground and stuff like that
he's a big fan of Star Wars that's kind
of cool yeah a little York's there
Eurasian from inspired by Luke Walker's
Skywalker's childhood at home
interesting Wow I love it sunk into the
ground with light filtering into the top
for homeless people interests no low
income and low income yeah the biggest
the biggest challenge and my friends in
this business now the biggest challenge
is low-income housing and so they're
there they're doing these you're gonna
see a very very different kind of models
people sharing space you're gonna see a
lot of it yep alien see Spa bless you
thank you what else this is a scary one
this is in China oh yeah man I didn't
see this it's crazy
so this guy's Simon Yam he was in a
movie with Angelina Jolie and he was
also an Ip Man he's a very very famous
star in China it man yep man it man so
anyways he was doing uh he was just
speaking in front of a crowd here and
then some random guy just walks up and
starts stabbing him I'll show you the
video here what
yeah that's why everyone has to be
careful thank you yep watch boom and
they start slashing his arms oh and no
one does anything does just Kirti right
there they finally get in oh my god
oh my god I took away to die and here's
an update on him
so his operation was a success and
apparently the guy that came up to him
was some just random guy that has mental
issues and thought he was someone else
and how can he just walk up this is
secure I know I know
how does he just walk up there that
guy's also so look at him super well
respected and loved in Hong Kong that
they just I guess they thought that no
one would do anything that's just crazy
yeah way to go security guards they have
to jump in immediately I'm scary Oh
looks like that youtuber who doing
meet-and-greets and I know fans walked
up shot her and trying to gut yeah that
was awful you just have to be super
aware of everyone around might be aware
when somebody just walks up like that
you know what you know yeah when I feel
like Donnellan that looked almost
obvious isn't that one I definitely
would have yeah yeah but us yet um how
about this so this is this accident
happen a year ago but a guy that played
from for LSU football he was a hunting
and a dog randomly when they were
loading up the truck to go hunting a dog
randomly jumped into the car or the
truck and then touched the safety part
like let go of that and then hit the
actual trigger
and it shot off his leg imagine that a
dog hits third safety and then hits the
trigger don't was a complete accident
gun loaded in the car hmm yeah well was
loaded but it had a safety on
yeah had the safety he's going hunting
he'll never have a loaded that's exact
anyways he's doing better now I still
he's gonna continue hunting yeah you got
a blown off by a shotgun I'm sure yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] Christ that's not good
that's terrible but that's just a really
really crazy you accident all right
moving on Tom Brady there's a little
video of him and jumping off a cliff
with his daughter and of course a lot of
people [ __ ] are mad yeah
not people like here's a bunch of
celebrity friends that are saying fun
stuff and cool stuff but
obviously people saying that they're
putting their daughter in danger or life
in danger
yeah because Tom Brady doesn't make good
choices I'll show you the video
[Music]
oh it's not really a cliff first of all
I means a cliff but it's so yeah it's
nothing
and then there's brief hesitation at the
end that's what people are also
criticizing it about it's fine I think
it's totally fine house Karen this I
wouldn't do that
hey what is the rock save it right there
it's a little scary he goes you know I
have complete faith in you as a man
friend playing fun but this just gave me
anxiety I agree man man as a dad I would
never do that I got to be honest well
chief she fought why he hesitated she
wanted to do it you're gonna hit her she
could have hit those rocks yeah that's
wonder Dupin and last second he already
left so and then behold Under Armour
yeah I was aware yeah yeah yeah I would
have I would have I would have held her
and jumped I wouldn't have done that I
would have held her that's me it's fine
cuz you kids will hesitate kids will
[ __ ] hesitate I don't I can't watch
that again oh but look at art this
[ __ ] no there's a lot of daughter
almost broke her arm and I fell should
consider serious punishment oh should
they here's another one this is
apparently the guy that started that
area 51 raid she did as a joke too but
this is him on barstool
I'll show you people kind of want to
know what's in there I think a lot of
people are gonna show up just because
it's kind of a meme but when people do
show up though we're working with some
great people we're planning something
really cool out there so I think last
time I checked it's like three million
people have RSVP'd it's either
interested or going so it's no small
number there was one gentleman that
messes the page from Denmark it said I
made their local news which I thought
was just completely wild I watch he
doesn't run here no what are you talking
about cat that's how they're gonna run
that's how they said they should run
he's security guards he's got a great
head piece there I don't know I know
it's from the anime oh it is yes he's
basically in a costume he's just joking
he's little things are troll Jensen joke
Yeah right but he looks exactly like
what I imagined
to work because we all it's amazing till
there's did you see [ __ ] to Lea's
video do you see the Instagram the video
he sent me mm-hmm bring up my Instagram
please and don't say anything don't look
just just watch the video watch this
[ __ ] what I got this morning I
had to post it this let's watch y'all
watch this
turn this up
zena's trailer
I can't find what having your career
[Laughter]
Jake it's so hello oh my god
that's hilarious this is a little longer
but this woman here she's a lawmaker
she's a legislator in Georgia and then
she was in line and had a supermarket
and she claims the white guy that wasn't
lying with her told her to go back to
where she came from and then she also
said that she was fearing for her life
and it was racism and all that stuff let
me show you this real quick here's a
news clip of it state lawmaker checkout
lane he said I called you a lazy piece
of [ __ ] yet that's all I say oh why did
you call a woman that too though so what
happened was she was in that freakin ten
items or less line and she had a bunch
of groceries and then she was like that
pissed the thing is I'm nine months
pregnant and I can't stand for a long
time so I was there I wouldn't usually
do it so the guy probably saw her coming
in going like what the [ __ ] he probably
knows she's pregnant a shot she was
super thick but not in a good way it was
like what the [ __ ] man and a rush of all
these yeah yeah what a dick
yeah he's a dick oh look at her this is
her you know I decided I decided to go
live because I'm very upset because
people are getting really out of control
with this I feel bad for her okay well I
saw another interview there are a lot of
people who are jumping on the [ __ ]
bandwagon that guy's dick don't call her
a lot I don't people on her side or his
no though the whole online community was
on her side but didn't watch everything
it just seems like she's okay but here's
the only thing and she's faking I think
she's
she's crying she's upset she's insecure
she's fat oh no she's pregnant she's
emotional
she's just famous intercut in a state
yeah but I mean there is a lie when
you're when you're a black woman like
that you know you hear all the [ __ ] you
see the world very densely more chin the
team also that guy's a dick so this guy
was actually going back to the grocery
store to complain and then she wanted to
do an interview with people yeah watch
this part wordy go back to where you
came from go back to your country or
where he came from
but he was making those types of
references is what I remember okay so
I'm gonna say he didn't say that I'm
gonna say this
he was guys the guys in an [ __ ]
laughing I'm sure I'm not a racist I
hate his guts cuz he said it to a
woman's he's not
not race it's not a race he claimed
racism that I think he's a piece of [ __ ]
I'm with Brian yeah he sucked 100 he's a
Sox not a race now though and now she is
in the spotlight or maybe he is a racist
a little dramatic I mean but but yeah I
think she's getting dramatic she's
dramatic by the way she was with her
[ __ ] 9 year old daughter if I had
seen that I would have lost my [ __ ] on
that off that's my girl Mike my groin
hey you were in line I would have been
like hey oh yeah you fight but if it's
you know my girls pregnant and this
issues with Tiger you've got some guy
started yelling at me because I hold him
coming up then yeah of course but I mean
I think just the fact that she was in
there that guy's grocery another grocery
line with a bunch of groceries she knew
she wasn't supposed to be in that line
already makes her feel like she's I
don't know but also the guy also says
later on that he's Cuban he's not even
white he's not Wow he's Cuban that's
what he says there's a whole lot of
malarkey going on in this video
hey you know I love bats was it dick for
sure they both showed up and slide to
argue the ban on camera oh it was great
that's a hilarious yeah and he goes no I
didn't say that I called you a fat piece
of [ __ ] they get get some color that's a
nasty thing to call something that's not
nice man and you know she's pregnant
our daughter [ __ ] is very very pregnant
or not she this girl she can't beat his
[ __ ] ass how exactly
maybe maybe Thanks so when you see that
description it just makes me that
skeptical eyes big time I'm about to be
very transparent cuz this is racism and
hate is getting out of control if I
caught racism I think it's fat shaming
if anything I think she heard for her
life right now everybody's antenna we're
all [ __ ] on edge
cuz that's because good old Trumpy Trump
and his trend his tweets and I think
everybody gets all polarized and Craig
has not racism now that's fat shaming
he's just a shameless fat shaming
that's bad shows you he's a he's
different he's a fattest and she could
cut in line
hey I think girl she's your little white
guy you know do you guys do that
Kim yes take like 30 pieces of groceries
to the 15 miles or less why she was I do
she move over that pregnant man it's
it's so uncomfortable I've been pregnant
wit huh she cut people in line though I
don't know if she cut but
I'm gonna guess that's maybe I don't
know you know I don't know what the hell
happened I just feel like just it
started off with her trying to defend
herself saying listen I went into that
line because I'm nine months pregnant
and this and that I don't know I don't
know you become Jin's bad person
no wait they chant after me white power
white but this is not alike at all this
is just fat yeah I don't like when they
call racism when it's not racism it's
just this guy's a dick yeah we're using
the word racism so much you have any
journalist with no real racism cuz this
is vegetable III my hope is I can't wait
to get to that [ __ ] you asked me what
my low energy was and I was having an
argument with the guy when I've had
lower energy than sighted show know any
other Hey
what All Saints must have been the
sample because it has the price tag
everything on the bottom oh it was the
sample yeah there you go damn you know
your fashion bra I guess man where you
just have a giant price tag on bottom
your shoes what else you guys got um
just two really quick ones this somehow
happened a cat fit this is a terrible
terrible story by the way a couple was
killed there was a homicide and for
whatever reason this live station they
had a snapchat type of filter through
the cat ears and they just popped up on
life to be huh
for me it was an accident well actually
it's activated during press colonies I
have to see this a couple they got
murdered in Canada I think yeah I think
so what happened
what's up American one Australian yes
yes that one yeah yeah what happened
they got murdered but matters pop up
yeah I just popped off you something it
murder what happened who they don't know
they're try figure out who just got
murdered on the side of the road they're
traveling around candidate I just
thought about a budget pictures with
them together it was really really sad a
real killer but this happened alright
moving off in this Avengers well do you
don't have video the catters
I try to find video there's no video of
it just pictures yeah whoa so avengers
endgame is now the highest grossing film
of all time
beating on Avatar I've never seen avatar
2 comes out to them 28 yeah hey James
Cameron took too long I'm out too took
too long
tick tick - hello
just like it Incredibles to the [ __ ]
on my face I don't know the characters
on the whole dynamic I'm out
avatar alright I'm out yep I never sighs
I haven't seen any of the Avengers
it doesn't look appealing to me
personally I'm not a target people love
them people absolutely love him I get it
I just I don't want to go back to have
to go through all them to understand all
of them and I don't watch all the
individual ones I don't I don't know
it's just not my thing
they're all in costume I like I like I
like comic book stuff though but I like
when it's like the original story I want
to go back to the whole [ __ ] mama's
here I mean sorry me too that's right
what else you got that's it
well bunch of racist stuff racist stuff
come see bein monk mohel then your
embrace Friday you don't break that
right for a while bye-bye I got a ghost
I go back to shooting my show Montreal
just the last comedy fest [ __ ] all in
August I'm shooting it all for the next
four months again oh well you have to
bounce yeah that's a pit master hmm I'll
work it out I'll work it out you'll
figure it out dealing days um everybody
come see me in Montreal Just for Laughs
comedy festival jf I don't know where
I'm gonna be I shouldn't I'm terrible
but yeah I'll be there you're blessed on
your social media class now buddy
then not this week next week two weeks
from now next Thursday Friday Saturday
I'm at Zanies in Nashville Bubba baby
bear eating chicken having a grand old
time that Nashville hot chicken
Nashville's Amy's I'm bringing in a mod
and Derek post in medium brown dangerous
Brown and big brown are in Nashville
baby baby and then after I'm in Portland
helium Portland Houston Denver just
added tip at kake.com for Brian and
myself and new Garrett area51 gear and
some other merch is dropping this week I
think is that right cat
I believe so t pack a dump for
everything Nashville see you next week
this is a fine kid we're out